I got fitted for clubs which is stupid I
got basically scammed
like how your clubs mean well they they
you go to like a simulator basically
they they like you know they make you
play on a simulator with and then they
test you out with different grips
different shafts different heads to see
like what oh
yeah they make you grip yeah grip
different shafts and yeah um they give
you head yeah this is what it looks like
Luke's showing us yeah Cody's fitted
clubs but back to your Club fitting
so this guy sucks you off you buy it you
bombs you had he gives you a head and
then he makes you grip his shaft so
that's the part where he got scammed you
woke up in his bed you're like yeah
and then he still made me pay yeah
I mean I do have really nice clubs now
but they you can't use them they cost me
an arm and a leg and some head